one of my friends invited me for pin
meeting and I saw you there and you were
a speaker I didn't understand much I
didn't understand nothing about the
property either even though I didn't
understand all your words I just felt
like I'm going to get this and for
another like five years I was follow you
through emails I said and I find you on
YouTube just just like that I mean I
didn't even searching for you you just
came to me and that changed my life
you've got a cleaning business your
husband's a builder and you've got a
maintenance business you've got a
property business how do you do it
what's the biggest tip so all the time
our money I recycled we invest for the
next one next day on my second deal I
didn't pay any deposit and I paid just
one month rent my third deal I negotiate
two and a half month free rental what
did your husband think when he saw the
money coming in I was so scared to tell
him I enroll for Academy I didn't want
to him to feel I will be failure but on
average how much are you making
well welcome to winners on a Wednesday
thank you it's been a long time coming
but honestly you're like a shining star
in the academy everybody is so inspired
by what you've done you've got a
cleaning business your husband's a
builder and you've got a maintenance
business you've got a property business
and how many rent events do you have now
into or how many of you signed in total
uh sign in total 2
26 26.
how do you do it what's the biggest tip
um I started with a little very small
Studio I was very determinated to to get
at least one and just start I was study
so hard your books I was listening to
your voice every day for a few hours a
day to be honest every time in the car
and I just take your energy so every day
I had your energy I felt like you and I
really want to be successful and started
with the one
which is really successful
um studio apartment and as soon as you
get your first one everything comes easy
easier and easier and now I don't even
need to search for properties that just
comes to me yeah and your your husband
is now working on the business yep and
your daughter my daughter yeah you've
actually sent her on the academy and
she's in her own right now become
financially free that's right following
in her mother's footsteps absolutely I
remember when she was so
shaking and she didn't know if it's good
direction she invests her all saving but
I mean at the moment when I see her
journey she's so appreciated and yeah
she's she's a queen now as well I
remember it was about six six eight
months ago and she was shaking and she
said you know she was working I think
what was she did she was an apprentice
or yes she was doing her dressing yeah
and then I remember sitting down with
her and she was like my mum says I've
got to do this but I'm not sure and I
was like look your mum loves you and you
know your mom's been successful and now
the fact that she's got properties yeah
as well so talk to me then for anyone
that's kind of wondering exactly what
the business model is how does it work
talk me through what rent to rent is
okay so rent to rent it's
it's a strategy when you rent property
for the landlord or agent and using
management agreement contractor you rent
it on a nightly basis and I use as a
service accommodation for my guests and
I charge super renter which allows me to
build my income yeah on someone's
property
so you're basically making cash flow
from a property that you're controlling
but not owning that's right what happens
if the landlord wants to do it himself
I've never had this situation but
they're so open and so nice and they
really support me as well the flats
which I've got in Brighton she the lady
my lady she used to run her flight as a
service accommodation but she said she
was too tired and she never had proper
cleaners and she had bad reviews and I
promised her listen I will be success I
mean just give me your house and I'm I'm
sure I would be success and I will bring
you the money which you want and at the
end I didn't even pay her deposited she
was so nice and we had really close
relationship together and she's so happy
I'm successful she it didn't work for
her but I mean she's happy I can do it
so why were you able to do it but she
wasn't I think she didn't well
definitely she didn't have
any knowledge I mean properly knowledge
she just wanted to start she had empty
flight yeah that was the issue and she
didn't know about where to search for
public cleaners where to advertise she
had double bookings the flood
people lied to her like when we arrived
to their Flats someone told her the
carpet was washed but we are
professional cleaning company and we
knew you know just someone came and and
spray some spray and clean like that the
thing is I think if you're not educated
and you're not wise you can be a bit
naive and people people can take
advantage and you can also have problems
as you mentioned like double bookings
that's right it's not just as easy as
getting a property and sticking it on
Airbnb you need to unders you need to
have a channel manager or you need to
synchronize your calendar you need to
really have good systems in place key
saves procedures and also it needs to be
legal it needs to be ran and a lot of
people don't realize that they don't
realize that there's some restrictions
in some areas what's been your main
patch what's been your area is born in
Brighton okay and at the moment mainly
in mainly in Eastbourne and I'm really
happy about Eastbourne some people
think this is very small town and
possibly nominee guests to my visit my
my city however I just realized is born
it's a town for retired people so my
income comes regularly
compared to the Brighton the nightly
base it's much higher however most our
bookings are during the weekends so in a
long term distance similar profit but in
here I've got consistency and it's cover
every month or every week in Brighton
brilliant profit but I mean I love my
con My Town Eastbourne is brilliant and
is that where you live at least that's
where I live here so I know I know I
know your daughter has got properties in
Brighton that's right that are very
successful but your patch is Eastbourne
Eastbourne and Brighton and Brighton and
Brighton so how do you do your market
research let's say somebody's thinking
of doing because you know you look on
the academy and you watch every week
winners on a Wednesday all different
strategies all different areas people
doing service accommodation even in
Birmingham Watford London Newcastle
you're doing it in Brighton and
Eastbourne but how do you do your market
research on an area before taking on a
property yeah I mean before I even
started I started really hard the patch
well actually I started yeah I started
about everything plus also my cleaning
company covers lots of service
accommodations and houses in eastborough
and Brighton so I knew occupancy rating
yeah and based on this I knew I will be
succeed yeah I spent hours so basically
I spent hours to just um sort of due
diligence do the due diligence yeah and
when you say you spend hours doing your
due diligence what sort of things do you
have to do how how do you do due
diligence on an area if you don't mind
giving the secrets yeah absolutely I
mean firstly when I chose the city which
I wanted to
settle my business or my service
accommodation I wanted to check
occupancy rate so I went on
airbnbnbooking.com
goes to most common websites for holiday
lights then I check the calendars how
other people and yeah for how many days
people are booked during the month and
the price is well I compare then when I
did my figures I always do best scenario
worst scenario and possible scenario in
a possible scenario if on a 50 occupancy
rate if I could earn at least some money
or even 100 pounds yeah I know that they
would be good and basically with me I do
not go anything less than 200 pounds for
50 base I know some people just do
diligent and even if it's zero they're
happy to take the deal yeah because
during the summer time usually the
occupancy is like 60 so they can get
some profit each month but I mean if
it's less than 100 200 I just rather go
for this different deal than just have a
castle hustle with and that 100 200
pound amount of profit that's sort of
like worst case if it only if it's empty
half the time yeah I still need to
making a bit of profit
um but on average how much are you
making so per per property what does it
typically what does an average month for
an average property look like okay so in
the summer time those two
my first
floods I earned 2K each two thousand
pound profit yeah
of your first two yeah no wonder you
went and got a lot more yeah and then we
took over I took over with lamara with
my business partner we took five bedroom
flat yeah and our first profit was 3
500k clean Profit just on one property
only one property we took together and
then we invest our money to get another
one so usually if we get the money from
the properties we've got for the month
monthly rent deposit and for the
furniture so all the time our money are
recycled we invest for the next one next
deal next so what about now in the
winter now it's winter I mean what kind
of profit like that that first property
that was making two grand a month what's
that making now so now the the one in
Eastbourne makes 600. okay I just did my
all numbers yesterday in Brighton about
800. wow and it was really quiet I would
say it was quite dead because I had like
50 just occupancy during the October
time all made 600 pounds so what would
you say
is your sort of like startup costs so to
be making that kind of money 600 pound
in the winter 2 000 pounds in the summer
on one property how much money do you
have to put down initially to get that
property up and running as I said my
first deal was the the most difficult
and I paid six months upfronto yeah to
get this deal why did you why did you do
that why did you pay so much rent up
front uh I really wanted I love
the how aflato I just fell in love I
knew it would be it's just close to the
train station close to the Sea perfect
perfect place and it was through the
agent my company wasn't
um existed for a long time on the market
and
and I just didn't know how to get this
house so the only option was to pay six
months up front but this first deal
helped me with the other deals because
like as I said my second deal I didn't
pay any deposit and I paid just one
month rent my third deal I negotiate two
and a half month free renter so I mean
it's just the first start it's it's just
when you determinated to have something
and to have on the paper like feedback
yeah to get more that makes sense so
basically you were sick if so your first
one because you had a brand new company
yeah
um I mean there are ways around it one
way is what you did just paying six
months rent up front sometimes people
will be a guarantor yeah or they'll
bring your guarantor in or they'll
co-rent your rent and they'll bring a
partner in
um but you've had six months rent up
front and how much rent were you was
that into what was the monthly agreement
so it's 600 pounds so I paid three
thousand six hundred so it's not crazy
amount of money and then that was making
you two grand a month throughout the
summer
and you use that to get your your second
your third and fourth and and start
building your portfolio yeah what have
been the biggest challenges with
management well as I said my husband
helps me a lot though what did he think
what did your husband think when he saw
the money coming in
um he doesn't say his dad
he did it I was so scared to tell him I
enroll for Academy oh really why why
were you scared I didn't want to
him to feel I will be failure or he
might think this is calm I knew I
strongly believe it but because I was
scared
he might
didn't like it so I didn't tell him
until I started to be succeed after
three months or something like that so
he he can Seize The Profit but I mean he
has a good connection he can't see my
account whenever he wants and now he
works he works in the company and he
works here well actually we opened
second company for him which is the
maintenance and lettings yeah so he's
happy now he's happy now yeah and he
takes lots of responsibilities as well
because he texting and messaging to
their customers and he likes well not
really likes but he helps me with
um with the bills as well like to see
who pays and who's not just to check the
account which I hated to do it I can go
and speak to people and everything like
your system he's my assistant here wow
and your daughter as well what did your
daughter think when she saw how well you
were winning and how many properties you
were getting what did she think after
you know a couple days ago after a
course when she attended to she said
Mommy could we join Venture
together and what did you say to her of
course yeah but you said you need to go
on the academy first you need to get the
training yeah why did you have interest
because some people would try and teach
their children what they've learned but
you might have done that but but you
sent your daughter yep to the actual
official training and said you need to
invest yep why did you do that I really
want her to be responsible responsible
for her decision
uh why I did that because
I saw she couldn't find the place for
herself she didn't know what she wants
to do and she was quite struggled with
with work with with college
she had lots of thoughts what to do but
she just needed Direction and when I
took her on the course
for one pound Crush course
I didn't tell her anything about
properties I just want to see her
feelings how she feels and is it
something for her and immediately she
said yes sir I want to do that and I'm
doing exactly the same with my son he
when he turned 16 it will be just in
couple months time I'm going to tell him
for the crash course yeah because I know
I just I've got like a feeling like a
mother he might be interested as well
he's not good at school and I said to
him well listen you don't need to he's
in GCSE class I mean you don't need to
read Christmas Carol remote Juliet
because I know how you hate reading but
if you could read
at least one book for me which I gave it
to him it's a rich dad poor data and
read two three pages per day yeah and
that's the only book I want you to read
you don't need to read anything else
because that book brings you the future
and brings you work money and whatever
you want your your dreams and not the
other books which you don't like it and
you need to read at school and he agreed
wow do you realize how much of a boss
you are am I I don't know
I mean what you've done is incredible
and it's and you and you're changing
your whole family and you're changing
the Next Generation what what's your
strongest reason for doing this what is
it that drives you I think on the
beginning
as I said I love challenges and I wanted
to learn new things but I didn't think
I can be successful I just didn't even
put into my mind I will be successful in
property I just wanted to do I wanted to
try
and I'm a person like if I start to do
something I'm doing with all my hard
time then I thought oh it would be so
lovely I love traveling so it would be
so lovely to go for Holiday once a month
and since April we just travel almost
every month somewhere it's it's amazing
when you've got funds to
to follow your dreams and that was my
dream that was my personal goal because
I I started as a single cleaner and I
know how hard it is to to work
physically for 10 12 hours every day and
they don't need to you know doing like
that and just calculate every penny oh
am I allowed you know to buy shoes today
or this month or not I just didn't want
the situation I just wanted them to
understand the money and do not work for
the money but just give them the
knowledge how money can work for them
right how have you scaled the business
because you mentioned that you started
just a single cleaner yeah on your own
now you've got a business you've got
people working for you you've got lots
of units how have you managed to
systemize that business it's still a
little bit struggle because I'm on the
way to find a good manager right I had
some few of them and good stuff it's a
challenge yeah yeah but mostly I mean
Claudia helps me a lot my husband helps
me a lot uh
and I am a workaholic I just work
many many hours but I love it this is
something what I love and until I feel
it this is this is more for pleasure not
for for the money it's it's amazing and
also you've got you know quite a lot of
properties that are cash flowing very
positive but now you're transitioning
obviously you're going to continue
running that business but you're
transitioning into development and
buying houses and developing them talk
to me a bit about that that's my yeah
that's my next goal um
I'm feel like
I'm a master at the moment with rent to
rent and I just want to step you know
next step which next step is brr and I
want to invest in property it up north
and
renovate them of course we we will use
my husband's company to to to to
renovate the property and just either
sit on a house or just sell it yeah and
get the money back and you've been
really smart because you've used rent to
rent to give you cash flow so you're now
financially free you don't have to work
you don't have to have a job but now
you've got a whole bunch of properties
and you're saving money and now you're
looking at reinvesting that into
building up your capital appreciation
your security which I think is is really
really smart how did you even get into
property in the first place what was it
that got you started yeah that's so
funny history
um one of my friends
invited me for Pin Meeting property
investment uh networking or something
like that that was in Eastbourne and I
saw you there
and you were a speaker like a 30 or 20
minute speaker I didn't understand much
I didn't understand nothing about the
property either just I love your energy
I saw your energy you know your
calculations how you
how you
talk to me even though I didn't
understand all your words I just felt
like I'm going to get this I'm going you
know follow your path and for another
like five years I was follow you
through emails you always I think I
enroll for something and you send me an
email so your company sent me an email
so I didn't even read because it was too
much and I didn't understand them but I
knew one day when my English developer
I'm going to find you
and suddenly I find you on YouTube just
just like that I mean I didn't even
searching for you you just came to me
and that changed my life it was
something about rent to rent and I
thought oh my God I'm going to sign for
one pound course in Brighton and since
then I wanted to do all the trainings I
wanted you know I felt growing up major
enough to to follow your papa wow so
when you first saw me you couldn't
really even speak any English much yeah
that's incredible and you've learned
English now you speak very well thank
you and and that's incredible how did
you justify
enrolling onto the academy because the
Academy's a very big investment
how did you justify that I had a savings
some savings which I use and with
Academia it was funnest story as well
because before I came for the course I
didn't understand I didn't even know
what is Academy but I just knew I really
want to be a part of the academy
and I've been searching for the guys who
can explain a little bit more because I
wouldn't be part of the family
and I didn't even hesitate it was just
quick decision I think I transferred
some money from few accounts and
actually we've been saving for for the
house and I said that's probably I
didn't even tell my husband what I did
just transferred the money I said I'm
ready you know to invest into my
education because some people would say
if you've got money you're better off
putting it into a house yeah but you
believe that your best investment is
yourself why do you believe that because
you know in the in the in a short period
of time like I don't know nine ten
months I got my money back plus I sit on
many you know on many properties I mean
I've got like an asset from
it's a passive income you know from
controlling other people's houses so
still I can buy a house if I want to
plus I've got income plus I've got
education plus I can teach my children
yeah better family lifestyle it's yes
it's brilliant and I think that you've
been a massive inspiration to a lot of
people and I'm excited for this video to
go out what would be your
best piece of advice to somebody that's
just beginning to get started in
property
it's never too late
English it's not an excuse and create
your reality
I love that well Isabella you've been a
dream to work with I hope you've enjoyed
being part of the academy very much
absolutely thank you so much and this is
just the beginning thank you Baldwin
you're awesome
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]